[Music]
as customers move workloads to Google
Cloud they need a native backup and
Disaster Recovery offering that provides
centralized management low RPO and RTO a
low total cost of ownership support for
a broad set of workloads and also one
that's easy to use
historically organizations of all sizes
would use multiple products for backup
Disaster Recovery recovery from
ransomware attacks and data replication
for various workloads furthermore since
no two workloads are alike these
architectures have high complexity and
potentially long backup and Recovery
times
needless to say those scenarios also
introduce high risk where organizations
really don't want to risk anything at
all whether rolling back a user error or
minimizing the impact of malicious
activity the ability to recover quickly
isn't just nice to have it's required
so we've built a solution that addresses
these challenges to give you peace of
mind introducing Google Cloud backup and
Dr a centralized Google Cloud native
backup and Disaster Recovery Solution
for cloud-based and hybrid workloads
we understand how critical it is for
your backup and disaster recovery
options to just work adding value in key
areas that matter with minimal
disruption to your business and
day-to-day operations so let's take a
look at how we get there first Google
Cloud backup and Dr stores backup data
in its application native format
as a result backup data for many
workloads can be made available directly
from the long-term backup storage with
no need for time-consuming data movement
or data translation thus accelerating
recovery of data and supporting rapid
resumption of critical business
operations
and of course it's not just about
features and capabilities it's about
value like reducing your RTO and
increasing confidence in your ability to
maintain business continuity all from
your Google Cloud console
we incorporate compelling trusted
technology while still prioritizing and
delivering Simplicity and ease of use
for example we placed a high priority on
delivering an intuitive centralized
backup management experience
with Google Cloud backup ndr
administrators can now leverage a Google
Cloud native centralized Management
console to effectively manage backups
spanning multiple workloads
admins can generate application and VM
consistent backups for VMware VMS Google
compute engine VMS databases and file
systems saving time and enabling
consistency and completeness in data
protection coverage
and while you can't put a price on peace
of mind we understand that minimizing
your total cost of ownership is also top
of mind so we designed Google Cloud
backup and Dr to implement space
efficient incremental forever backup
technology to ensure that our customers
pay only for what they truly need with
incremental forever backup Google Cloud
backup ndr performs full backup only
once initially and all the subsequent
backups are incremental in nature
meaning that only data that has changed
since the last backup is stored this
minimizes the network traffic and I O
load on the production infrastructure
thus helping to keep Associated
infrastructure costs low and it also
minimizes the amount of storage consumed
by the backups so our customers also
benefit via reduced storage consumption
costs
we also support flexible backup storage
options so when choosing to store
backups on Google Cloud Storage you are
able to select the appropriate storage
class like standard nearline or cold
line for your specific needs we want to
make Cloud infrastructure easier to
manage faster and less expensive and by
centralizing backup Administration and
applying Cutting Edge storage and data
management Technologies we've eliminated
much of the complexity time and cost
associated with traditional data
protection Solutions
Google Cloud backup and Dr enables
customers to manage Backup and recovery
from a Google Cloud native centralized
Management console
reduce RPO and RTO with efficient data
capture and on-demand rapid recovery
minimize TCO leveraging a simple
cost-effective consumption-based pricing
model integrated with Google Cloud
billing
and protect a broad range of workloads
and use cases to deliver comprehensive
data protection
and the best part is you can try it for
yourself today find backup ndr in the
operations section of the cloud console
and check it out
[Music]